bonsoir l'intérieur vraiment soit les
tests nous sommes sur la terre est
toujours en compagnie de neuf burki
balkany et gilles lellouche
et de nicolas bedos
alors patrick balkany re bonsoir donc je
vous rappelle que vous êtes député maire
de levallois perret ça va vous êtes
toujours à l'aise devant les caméras au
bois depuis le temps c'est l'habitude de
la vidéosurveillance a fait valoir à ça
j'ai été le premier à mettre les caméras
maintenant tout le monde en est oui bien
comme une caméra levallois perret en a
pas tant que ça finalement on va en
rajouter
et on a passé tout le monde en réclame
si la ville où il ya intérêt sentir
maquis et parce que les journées c'est
vrai qu'on voit bien avec nos caméras
même la nuit oui et on arrive à lire une
plaque minéralogique à 200 m oh là là
alors il faut pas brûler les feux rouges
quelle horreur c'est vraiment génial
mais ça évite les accidents voilà quel
est l'endroit le plus étrange via les
caméras de surveillance dans votre ville
y en a partout mais si on baisse dans un
bar gay bon il faut que tu allais à
l'auteur il y en a pas les moyens
d'aller à l'hôtel mais je sors
n'habitent pas de valloire je savais pas
de vous aviez encore ses déviances
derrière bis en suffisance et moi je
suis fiancée aux invités ce soir parce
que dans ces temps devant tous besoin de
retrouver confiance dans la politique je
tenais à avoir à mes côtés celui qui se
définit lui même comme l'homme le plus
honnête du monde
dans cette émission vous savez
il vaut mieux à quand on fait de la
politique oui parce qu'on est vous avez
remarqué extrêmement
surveillé oui par les médias lue par les
procureurs par les juges oui et tout le
monde essaye toujours de vous trouver
des noirs et donc il vaut mieux être
clim
jette pas par exemple l'homme politique
le plus honnête du monde par rapport à
pasqua non
pasqua moi j'ai beaucoup d'admiration
pour pour pasqua qui était un grand
ministre un grand ministre de
l'intérieur qui a été un grands patrons
v des hauts-de-seine grand président du
conseil général je vous dire si vous
voulez pas être honnête faut faire autre
chose que de la boue et personne n'a
jamais fait de politique vous êtes quand
même offert le faire cogiter congrès de
l'argent vous pouvez quand même utiliser
la conjugaison pour dire je suis devenu
récemment honnête mais mais mais le
présent est un peu affirme annette un
peu et humble gonflé je ne vois vraiment
pas qu'est ce qui vous autorise parce
que qu'est ce qui vous autorise à dire
des choses pareilles je vous rappel des
faits qu'elle confierait que vous parlez
de la de la confiance que les français
doivent retrouver à la politique vous
voyez un homme qui comme vous a eu des
démêlés avec la justice oui on m'a
reproché il ya 20 ans d'avoir employé
quelqu'un qui recevait les chefs
d'entreprise qui servait comme le font
tous les ministres
c'est derrière moi vous avez raison vous
avez raison mais c'est normal à un
moment donné il ya vous les gens ont de
la mémoire c'est normal que que ça
puisse paraître main descendant balkany
la caméra est dit je salue l'homme le
plus honnête il soit dans cet agaçant
monsieur bedos a fait trente ans que je
suis maire oui vous savez réélu par une
population qui voit ce que je fais dans
ma ville et si je suis député depuis 88
c'est pas par hasard c'est parce que je
suis élu au suffrage d'universe massage
d'euros malone et vous y frotter un jour
et j'ai pas que ça vous verrez que ce
n'est pas si facile et quand on veut
donner des leçons jda n'a pas de sens
quand on veut donner des leçons aux
politiques allez vous faire élire
nouveau cet été quand même qu'on puisse
plus grand critique est un homme
politique sans être passés soit même pas
le suffrage universel
ça va être de plus en plus compliqué de
commenter la politique s'il faut
soi-même être élu gilles t'es pas obligé
de faire la gueule que tu fais dans ton
film
et
bon
rien cette mise au point est en fait
toute façon vous n'êtes pas impliqué et
patrick dans les affaires qui
empoisonnent la vie de votre grand ami
sarkozy karachi kadhafi bettencourt
arbitrage tapis voilà pourquoi
maintenant pourtant vous êtes pote a
vécu je suis très ami avec nicholas carr
instant que vous êtes ami avec une
absolument c'est l'époque où son père
était aux usa et lui sarko il n'avait
pas de blé il était tout seul et vous
vous l'aidiez oui c'est vrai oui moi
j'étais déjà mariés y venaient manger à
la maison
j'avais une affaire de prêt-à-porter ils
veulent s habiller bon très bien voilà
c'était bon vous l'avez idées je les ai
d'eads était jeune il a six ans de moins
que moi ils étaient 1 c'est son droit il
n'avait pas de soul le samedi et le
dimanche s'il allait bosser il allait
vendre des glaces le samedi vente des
fleurs le dimanche se trimballer les
gros pots etc et puis après il est
devenu maire de neuilly très bien alors
ce qui vous avait rapproché en fait
c'est que vous êtes d'origine hongroise
tous les deux et en revanche lui son
père insu mais pas très bien son rôle de
père de famille alors que voulait il
était divorcé voilà voilà alors que vous
allez y avait de l'argent votre père il
allait et conduite exemplaire pendant la
résistance déporté à auschwitz mois des
résistants officier de la légion
d'honneur médaille militaire voilà c'est
à dire avant d'avoir été naturalisée
française en 49 voilà et ensuite votre
père a monté une entreprise de
prêt-à-porter tout à qui s'appelait réty
tu t'en souviens pas il faisait des
bikinis avait des voitures réplique y
circuler dans paris non mais c'est vrai
ça marche a dit y avait du pognon commun
il y avait de quoi s'occuper de ce
pauvre nicolas sarkozy
alors j'ai toujours défendu nicolas
sarkozy bec et ongles et quand jean
françois copé veut faire un bilan du
quinquennat vous dit jean françois copé
ferait mieux de faire l'inventaire des
conneries de la gauche depuis un an ce
qu'il ne fait d'ailleurs pas beaucoup en
ce moment alors c'est le pendant l'été
copé quand c'était pour la présidence de
l'ump vous le soutenir je ne sais est
pensé pour les visées vous le soutenez
pas du tout écoutez je pense très
sincèrement que cette bataille pour
l'elysée est tout à fait prématuré
c'est dans quatre ans rappelons que je
suis contre ces écuries présidentielles
je pense que on en a le temps d'en
parler moi je souhaite que nicolas
sarkozy revienne le moment venu c'est
lui qui décidera s'il revient s'il
revient pas et puis ça sera le moment de
parler des présidentielles pas
aujourd'hui alors dû vous êtes là on va
en profiter sur la syrie quelle est
votre position et la pression de sarkozy
est ce que comme en libye vous voulez
remplacer un dictateur l'aïd par une
dictature islamique et est déstabilisé
toute une région je pense que vraiment
on ne peut pas intervenir la base sans
qu'il y ait vraiment une coalition et
sous couvert de l'onu on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui nous les français parce que
le président de la république a décidé
de d'être le général va-t-en-guerre de
partir régler tous les problèmes qui se
posent partout cela dit ce qui a été
fait est parfaitement horrible même
dégueulasse d'avoir envoyé un des gages
sur les gens sayah il ya aucun problème
mais ce qui est curieux c'est que tant
qu'on l'ait tué à coups de fusil ou coup
de canon tout le monde trouvait ça
normal et quand il ya sont morts avec l
gaz sarin alors l'intérim cela dit les
français pensent et à juste titre que ce
n'est pas leur guerre mais que ce n'est
pas à la vie n'était pas là les
chaussures leur avait demandé j'étais
pas non plus trop plein
oui nous n'avons pas d'intérêt
particulier en syrie nous n'avons pas
d'intérêt français particulier à
protéger là bas me suis dit est-ce qu'on
est obligé d'intervenir simplement ou à
cause des intérêts particuliers qu'on
avait payé ce qu'on pourrait pas juste
intervenir par par altruisme ou
simplement pour sauver des gens qui se
font massacrer oui avec un peu de
noblesse s'en sert et aucun je ne sais
pas je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
vous et c'est le rôle de l'onu et l'ue
était normal même si le conseil de
sécurité s'y opposait parce que les
russes et les chinois s'y opposaient ce
qui aurait été normal c'est que ben
kemoun le secrétaire général convoque
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
et fassent voter à la majorité simple
l'intervention par l'onu qui à ce moment
là aurait pu récupérer des soldats des
avions etc dans toutes les grandes
puissances et intervenir au nom de l'onu
mais la france n'est pas gendarme du
monde mais l'opinion voit bien là même
son incapacité à gérer cette situation
mais non tu sais très bien donc
clairement donné va faire mal à être
actif on n'a pas regardé ce massacre
éternellement je dire si on est d'accord
mais on ne peut pas aller nos tout seul
s'il n'y a pas les pas question d'y
aller tous à 6h paraguay s'il ya le
talent coalition des grandes puissances
militaires quand il est impossible d'y
aller seul si colas d'angély est ce que
tu penses que l'armée française doit
rétablir l'ordre à marseille ou en syrie
où là je suis bien trop lâches pour
répondre à cette question on va parler
de la syrie ça ferait pas mal pour
mettre un peu de militaires dans
certaines banlieues
à droite qu'on est malade ou samia ghali
qui socialisent qu'avec l'amsa
si monsieur
valls n'est pas capable de régler le
problème il faut qu'ils s'adressent à
leurs ayants sont pas encore parties
écrire non elle en fait oui j'ai fait
j'ai fait un rêve au mois de juillet
pardon c'est pas contre vous
personnellement que
dans le mot rêve je me balade gt gt ils
étaient tous sur une plage des fabulous
valse balkanique copé il était en
bermuda comme ça ils étaient en train
déjà de préparer leur petit tacle leur
petit claj leur petit buzz de l'année
qui s'annonce avec les mêmes des
journalistes et a pâti toute la clique
il était là sur la plage il y avait un
immense tsunami
qui arrivé comme ça au loin et tout le
monde
mais au moins on mettait des nouvelles
tronche dans la sauce de la société
civile il restait plus personne à bord
voyez nicholas ray c'est pour ça que je
vais pas à la plage
je veux passer mes vacances sur les
hauteurs et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus